Speaker 1: Let's go next to Daisy from Is
it from reading or from reading? Reading.
And it's spelled reading. But I know that
it's pronounced different ways depending
on where in the world we are talking about.
Speaker 3: Yeah, it's. It's reading, actually.
How are you doing? David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well. We have significantly
degraded audio quality where it's the sort of like
robot voice thing that's happening. But let's see
if you can get your question in, if nothing else.
Speaker 3:
Oh, boy. Okay. Can you hear me
better, I hope. My question is,
in the Republican Party, they seem to focus
around trends. People. And I think it's because,
in my view that that with trans people, they are
making changes to their bodies with like. You know
what? Whatever their doctors recommend. Right. And
they and the Republican Party is attacking this
in a way that they haven't attacked. What do the
the in the past like with the the gay community,
for example? And I'm just wondering your thoughts
about whether they will ever let up on the trans
community like give us a break. Kind of.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I think so. I mean,
as I've said before, for a while, it was like,
when will they stop obsessing about gay men and
gay sex? And the answer, unfortunately for
the trans community was when they moved on
to being obsessed with the trans community.
I do believe eventually Republicans will move
on. The problem is they'll scapegoat some
other group so someone else has it coming
to them if they if you know what I mean.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I understand that. I'm
just. I'm hoping for something to change. I see a
lot of change happening, and I think it's Montana
with the missile silenced by the. I think
they'll let the Republican legislature.
Speaker 1: Daisy, you cut out when you
said who was silenced. But let me look
into what's happening in Montana. I'm going
to let you go. Just because the connection
is really an uphill battle for us. But I do
appreciate your question and hearing from you
about what is a very important issue. I do
believe they will move on from transpeople,
but someone else is going to then be in
their crosshairs, which is a scary thing.